[Music]
there are so many huge celebrities that
are fans of drag race and i know you've
found a fan and somebody by the name of
ariana grande
when she followed me on instagram i'm
not even embarrassed to tell you that i
i ugly cried i've been a fan of hers
forever i remember walking home after a
gig like four in the morning and it was
like sunrise and i was listening to her
dangerous woman album
and i didn't know what was around the
corner because this is before it started
dragged but i i knew um
that
something was
changing within me and i knew that
something was shifting and
some level of like i need to give you
know
less f's about life and just be free was
sort of on the surface and that she's
the one that i associate with that
change whenever i've mentioned her in a
story or something she'll always be
really sweet and just be like oh you
look great or like you know i love you
whatever and i'm like i am obsessed with
you
[Music]
the work the world tour i have been to
many but yes and i love it because you
get to see so many incredible drag
artists all on one stage what are you
loving about being on the work the world
tour i can only imagine
that with so many drag artists there's a
whole lot of fun and a whole lot of
drama too yeah i mean it wouldn't be
dragged without the drama that's kind of
why we love it you know i'm a performer
i feel
so alive when i'm on stage and there's
so much stress and drama that goes into
just getting on stage right obviously
getting into drag learning your
choreography learning your words you
know working with the dancers and then
you add the lights and the wind and the
screaming people but i had a moment
yesterday after our first show in
hamilton where i just was like ah
nothing beats this this feeling of being
on stage i feel like lady gaga or
britney or someone i feel like a pop
star you're a bit silent but deadly
you know what really smelly farts
really smelly farts silent but deadly
but honestly i feel like a lot of times
drag artists feel like they have to be
the loudest person in the room i will
say when i came to drag race i thought
you know i've got
a lot of ammunition in my belt in terms
of like what i'm good at you're the most
powerful when i'm performing i don't
feel the most powerful when i'm in a
room full of other really loud people
when i hit that stage i'ma drive you
crazy serve it to you like a lady and i
went in there thinking i i don't know if
i really fit into this world rue took me
aside at one point and was just like you
know
just
relax be yourself
let people fall in love with you you
don't have to do anything else just be
yourself and when she tells you that
you're like okay yes ma'am absolutely
but i think drag let me
um strip down some of the sort of
conservative notions of how to be and
how to be perfect
and how striving for perfection is nice
to get you from a to b but to get from a
to z you've got to let all that crap go
all right well since there are so many
dates in canada thank you on the work
the world tour i'm going to test your
canadian knowledge
which drag artist do we refer to as the
queen of the north recognized yes
correct ballerina baby who is the prime
minister
of canada
pete budage
incorrect what is the biggest city in
canada
is that this is like a trick question is
it toronto no you're right okay you're
right hey what is canada's national
anthem
um
um
shania twain i feel like
correct i will give that to you it's
actually oh canada but um that should be
it
let's go girls what are the colors of
the canadian flag and what is the symbol
oh oh i know this one it's a white no
excuse me it's either white or red and
it has a maple leaf
so i'm going to give that to you because
it's white and red and has a maple leaf
so great job yay i'm killing it you're
kicking idiots you are killing it i mean
hey thanks for watching et canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos